- What are we doing?
Jacob Blake’s father asked that same
question after learning that his son
was shot seven times in the back.
After learning that Kenosha
Police tried to murder his son.
After learning that his grandkids
watched it all happen in the backseat.
- [Jacob Blake Sr.] Like he didn’t matter.
- What are we doing?
♪♪♪ They trainin' officers to kill us, then
shootin' protesters with these rubber bullets. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ They regular people, I know that they feel it. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ These scars too deep to heal us. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ What happened to COVID? ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Nobody remember. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ It ain't makin' sense. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ I'm just here to vent. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ It happen to one of your people, it's different. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ We get it, the system is wicked. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪Just learn how to pick it. ♪♪♪
- What are we doing?
Can anyone answer that?
- It’s exhausting being Black.
- We are scared as Black people.
- Because this isn’t the first time
a Black person has asked that.
- If not now, when?
- [Master] Maya Moore wants to know.
George Hill wants to know.
Jaylen Brown wants to know.
What the hell are we doing?
- All you hear is Donald Trump and
all of ‘em talking about fear.
We’re the ones getting killed.
- COVID-19 ain’t the only pandemic
that can shut down the NBA.
- [Ernie Johnson] NBA teams refusing to play their
scheduled games in protest of racial injustice
- We’re not responsive to perception
when we’re trying to change reality.
- I think it’s best for me to support the
players and just not be here tonight.
- So what are we doing?
We’re protesting to be heard.
- Don’t listen to these people telling
you, “Don’t do anything because
it’s not gonna end right away.”
- Embrace it and be the change
because you are the change.
♪♪♪ We goin' ultra black. ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ I gotta toast to that. ♪♪♪
- We’re voting for change in November.
We’re fighting against voter suppression
- We need everybody to register to vote.
- Vote.
- We’re not being silent.
We’re demanding an answer.
- Wearing a T-shirt is not enough.
- We need to be able to create
those avenues for people.
- You gotta be better.
You gotta do better.
You gotta want better.
- [Julia Jackson] Let’s use our love and our
intelligence to show the rest of the world
how humans are supposed to treat each other.
♪♪♪ No matter your race, to me, we all are black. ♪♪♪
- [Master] And as each game in the
playoffs grows more important, we can’t
ever forget what’s most important.
So what are you doing?